bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fuori j
oggi siamo su penombra eravamo rimasti
che pif ci aveva letteralmente caricati
nel corridoio di bianco e io sono corso
qui dentro per salvarmi ok c'è questa
porta chiusa è per aprirla devo
praticamente trovare una sega e non mi
chiedete perché anzi l'ho trovata la
sega l'ho già trovata la prima dove c'è
la pif a sto punto raga quindi direi di
provare a metterla anche se non so che
cosa serve
va bene la fanta bene bene bene bene
sono trascorsi esattamente dodici giorni
11 ore e 39 minuti e 12 secondi l'ultima
volta che è successo qualcosa di buono
che cazzo sta facendo si sta seccando
che cazzo è successo ok ok ok ok ok ok
questo è un amico di bip aiuto l'aiuto
ovvio chiudila chiudi la porta ma
edizione ma la tengo dalla maniglia così
non entra
ok ok ragazzi è un problema questo c'è
il fratello di pif che mi segue tieni la
valetta porta no no no ok no
no no no no no no no no ok perfetto
faccio tipo ezio lo chiudono chiedo chi
la merda merda merda merda merda pretty
apriti o cazzo cazzo cazzo si è già
aperto maledizione ma l'inizio quanto
cazzo sei sexy
ok ok ok ok se non dirmi che desse la
perla perfetto che ho fatto l'ho chiuso
chiuso una crociera quella fare io
quella porta non l'aprirono mai più
ok andiamo a sedico ha subito
immediatamente ci sono delle pile va beh
io santissimo fatemi controllando
secondo cosa c'era qui dentro perché non
ho visto questa veramente raga non me
l'aspettavo per niente c'è stata una
cosa veramente assurda
ci sono del cos'è cos'è sta roba le
schede di circuito sono tutte bruciate
perfetto ci sono cos'è non so che cosa è
però le schede di circuito sono tutte
bruciate
penso che io debba cambiare da questo
punto
[Musica]
ebbene devo tornare indietro non so dove
andare forse questa una scheda di
circuito no l'installazione serve
maledizione
non so dove andare da as ice la porta
che è aperta che che ha sfondato il
fratello di pif perfetto
entriamo qui dentro adesso chiudo la
porta perché non voglio che entri
nessuno perfetto e c'è un libro bene non
so cosa devo fare c'è un computer posso
controllare facebook no come al solito
non si accenderà allo schermo nostro uno
schermo di messaggi di errore ci sarà
pure un modo per ripararlo sono un
sistemista riparo tutto cos'è questo
scheda blu ce ne saranno altre qui
intorno probabilmente raga è sono le
schede bruciate dell'altra stanza devo
trovarne delle altre di sicuro perché se
non posso andare avanti è perfetto l'ho
trovato
che culo la seconda scheda verde me ne
manca una che non trovo perfetto erap in
bella mostra sulla scrivania ma io
naturalmente non l'ho vista bene apriamo
i cassetti soltanto per vedere se ho
dimenticato qualcosa e poi prova a
tornare nella stanza di prima benissimo
raga sto salvando impasti candoni ogni
volta come al solito
va bene non so cosa devo fare il
computer ovviamente non posso usarlo
quindi direi di tornare nella stanza di
prima
sperando che il fratello di pif non si
sia liberato
ok ok ok ok imperfetto non voglio
avvicinarmi di più a quella porta
maledetto dici che vuole solo un
abbraccio perché non lasci entrare ma
guarda in questo momento non sono in
vena di abbracci però veramente lo
ringrazio
cos'è sta roba nessuna scheda rilevata
nello slot
ok mio zio che casino
va beh direi di andare nella stanza di
fianco a riparare qui cose prima di
tutto perfetto c'è la scheda blu la
scheda verde la scheda rossa io ce l'ho
tutte e tre a dalla scheda blu non mi
pare funzioni correttamente credo che la
scheda via bisogno di qualche modifica
ok devo inserirla nel computer
probabilmente prima non so cosa devo
fare però precisamente
ce l'ho fatta dopo un'ora e mezza a
mettere roba a caso ce l'ho fatta ragalo
configurato le tre schede praticamente
dovevo guardare della roba qui sul
manuale del computer
però io e leggere manuali non me la cavo
benissimo quindi ci ho messo lo stesso
mezz'ora ma alla fine ce l'ho fatta ho
configurato le tre schede e adesso devo
riuscire a metterle qui dentro allora ho
visto qui a quella dell'inter face va
bene no no perfetto ok è questa e altre
due devono mettere nei pannelli
superiori ma proviamo a lanciarlo
vediamo se ci arriva
perfetto ok ragano in panca una e poi
abbiamo finito
se dio quale usciamo da questa
maledettissima stanza effetto finalmente
si sono riaccese le luci maledizione non
ne potevo più ok posso andarmene di
qualcosa è servita sta cosa non me lo
chiedete non so se si è riattivata la
corrente non interessa aprire la porta
comunque torno indietro
ok ora che si è accesa la corrente
sinceramente non so che cosa devo fare
ma va beh torniamo indietro
probabilmente era la corre hanno il
computer il computer hanno dimenticato
che ce la sto compito ha spento un
perfetto operazioni in corso grotta
punto peak ok
questa era la grotta oddo era la grotta
di overture ma ricordo il controllo
blocco forte e vi porta questa volta ci
siamo ragazzi gay sono sicuro che li di
giusto e di porta non valido maledizione
ero convinto che fosse questo va beh e
abbiamo la il computer per sbloccare una
porta ci manca da capire quale la porta
da sbloccare intanto va c'è la sega di
prima che può tornarvi utile vabbè raga
direi di uscire a questo punto anche
perché non so qual è la porta che posso
aprire devo probabilmente prima a
trovarla e poi tentare di aprirla perché
se non ha senso
ok ryan non ho la più pallida idea di
dove debba andare però qualsiasi posto è
meglio di questo di prima
a parte il fatto che qui prima c'era pif
che correva ma quelli sono dettagli
speriamo di non incontrarlo e ci sarà un
casino di porte che non ho ancora aperto
tipo questa non ho idea di dove porti o
questa cosa è uno spogliatoio
eh no non era qua dentro una capacità
orientativa di una banana
non so dove andare raga cos'è questo
ok storage machine room dove siamo noi è
qui dietro non ho capito che cosa cela
la porta non si apre non ci sono
serrature c'è scritto id 3.061 perfetto
naga l'abbiamo già trovato forse dovrà
usare qualche utensile perfetto 3.061 ve
lo ricordate perché non me lo ricorderò
mai storage cos'è sta roba
non l'ho aperto aperto prima lo storage
no vero ok non mi ricordo già più lidi
quindi meglio che non vada tanto in giro
che vada di nuovo al computer il prima
possibile perché mi sto già
dimenticandoli di della porta ad aprire
comunque è bene c'è una porta quindi
cos'è chi è quello ovvio dio c'è
qualcuno ragali dietro non voglio sapere
sinceramente chi è l'uomo dall'altra
parte del vetro in mano una specie di
maschera antigas servirebbe anche a
messi infatti quella maschera mi serve
raga per passare il punto però prima ci
deve arrivare ci sono sti cosi forse
riesco a superarli tipo in tipo l'inizio
di penombra vai che atleta manco il
salto con l'asta
guarda qui sembra guardarti sembra si la
corteccia ottica di questa scimmia è
sicuramente più silvia è giustissimo di
interrompersi mese ti vanti di risolvere
problemi logici lasciate che lo dica con
parole povere il 2 medico e che io
voglio che tu veda vuol dire che tu puoi
farmi vedere qualsiasi cosa voglio la
nutella perfetto non funziona come
immaginavo raga non funziona è quindi
dice soltanto puttanate però come al
solito c'è il detersivo da scolare se lo
vogliamo
va beh sinceramente non voglio fermarmi
più di tanto devo prendere la la
maschera antigas cazzo ok sono diventato
una sottiletta c'era una pressa che mi
ha schiacciato di brutto ok raga prova a
passarvi sopra a sto punto dato che non
riesco a passati sotto
ci riesco però a saltare tipo sopra si è
perfetto cioè fatemi capire se io passo
di sotto mi schiaccia ma se ci salto
sopra regge tranquillamente perfetto c'è
qualcosa che in a leva perfetto
tiriamola un interruttore siro vedo
anch'io se magari la tv mi fanno piacere
c'è il detersivo come al solito devo
riuscire ad arrivare all'interruttore se
ci riesco finalmente hai un braccino
corto come non so cosa è o disattivato
anche le trappole perfetto essa porta
penso si sia aperta ok ok c'è una
maschera antigas che devo prendere
perfetto ok ci sono dei veleni merda
deve uscire di qua si ricapitolando devo
aprire la porta che non mi ricordo il
codice 30 61 la porta rimasta sempre
chiusa fortunatamente ok
come non detto ok ok ciao ciao pip di
nuovo qui come sai
ok corri corri corri corri corri corri
corri merda merda non mi ricordo che la
porta di prima e questa maledetto cliff
e cassa che brutto stronzo di merda tu e
tuo fratello brutti maledetti stronzi
griffe raga è qualcosa di imprevedibile
spunta quando meno te l'aspetti comunque
non [ __ ] di brutto e di porta 30 61
mi pare di ricordare la porta ora aperta
perfetto
adesso devo tornare indietro ma c'e pif
che corre nei corridoi porca [ __ ]
e vabbè noi proviamoci lo stesso taghavi
giura non riesco più a trovare la stanza
velenosa ok perfetto come non detto
bene allora mettiamo la maschera antigas
e stavolta dovrei riuscire a passare
perfetto kitsch è permesso
e nessuno ok ma poi ragazzi 10 metri
potevo farli anche trattenendo il
respiro però vabbè dettagli è ok e posso
togliermelo è sempre perfetto c'è ma tu
mi vuoi dire che non riusciva a
trattenere il respiro per 5 secondi
vabbè cazzacci tua comunque va beh c'è
una roba bloccata come al solito e mi
pare di aver controllato tutto dietro di
me quindi non c'è più niente da
controllare questo mi diciamo mi da soli
a parte si da biblioteca che chiusa ma
ma per aprirla sinceramente non so come
si fa quindi direi di proseguire di qua
perché di sicuro è l'unica via per
andare avanti allora il motore non
funziona cosa devo fare qui in altro
enigma no vi prego è chiusa ma la
serratura sembra grezzo ok una sega non
penso che basti non taglierà il metallo
se ci avevo pensato cos'è cos'è questo
c'è un tubo ok faccio tipo la madonna
che genio che genio mai stancati se fa
vj fracassa tutto che genio ragazzi lei
di proseguire
l'ho fatto completamente a caso ci sono
altre batterie perfetto
ok c'è un altro computer spero non ci
sia un'altra videochat perché non ci
sarei con quella [ __ ] però va bene ok
statistiche pressione vapore ma che
cazzo è sta roba attivazione modalità
manuale fallita per priorità valvole 56
89 ragazzo non so che cosa sto facendo
non ha idea di che cosa ho fatto
però qualcosa avrò fatto cos'è sta roba
non funziona correttamente probabilmente
devo ripararlo no si apre a mano
buongiorno è ora di alzarsi si sono le
gocciole ok
salve svegliati brutto stronzo ma gli
schiaffi oddio cosa devo fare qui dentro
ragazze un interruttore ok allora il mio
amico mi dispiace lasciarlo qui perché
nessun segno visibile di traumi by di
sicuro morto io non ci spererei tanto
comunque la porta si apre non si sposta
merda sono bloccati dentro
oddio tutto bene oddio oddio
c'è un verme gigante ok ok merda
apri apri oggi abbia b parlano funziona
sopra ma cos'è ok ragazzo non è la merda
suono della meta di un verme che mi sta
beccando
no io apre
mi ha travolto la gamma sono ancora vivo
merda aiuto il cazzo
abbiamo noi
ok ok ok ok
la stanza raga non so come fare vi giuro
non so come fare sulla terra non si apre
però la porta maledizione aiuto aiuto
forse riesco
sì se sono riuscito a salire qui sopra
e adesso posso pensare che cosa fare ok
ragazzi
beh forse ho capito non sono sicuro però
merda ti porta ok perché sono sceso
merda
arriva di quarata voglio provare a fare
una cosa però non sono sicuro che
funzioni
ok merda mer gio dio merda merda
no no
non mi hai preso ok deve arrivare gli
desse
a provare a fare sta cosa
una forchetta
mi ha preso in pieno ok merda merda
merda non solo dove arriva come fatto
dio sindaci prova viaggio
crepa bastardo ho vinto ho vinto io ho
vinto io ho vinto io
è troppo è troppo tardi per sbatte la
testa contro il muro fino a morire
sarebbe più facile che andrà avanti lo
stronzo viscido di merda vinto
che cos'è oddio c'è una mano perché c'è
una mappa
mi scusi se la prendo ma mi serve per
avere la porta grazie mille il nostro
amico di sotto mi sa che avrà compagnia
per un bel po
io me ne vado ok è chiudo anche la porta
per sicurezza non ci entrerò mai più
raga direi di chiudere qui l'episodio
perché veramente è successo di tutto
cercano rifare episodi abbastanza lunghi
avevo in mente di farne anche uno da
un'ora si è super umbria ma anche su
happy meals perché me l'avete chiesto in
tanti più avanti vedrò di farlo di
sicuro e vabbè a sto punto salvo
come al solito la luce abbagliante non
manca mai comunque raga direi che posso
chiedere l'episodio come sempre se vi do
è piaciuto lasciato un commento mi piace
anche alla pagina di facebook come in
ogni video trovate nella descrizione se
non sei da codesti iscrivetevi noi ci
vediamo al prossimo video bella ragazzi